yeah this news is a few days old so if
you haven't heard by now I'd be
completely surprised it's been announced
who's going to play Wonder Woman in Man
of Steel 2 / Batman vs Superman /
probably Justice League at this point
and I wasn't even gonna make a video
about it but a lot of you guys were like
you should it sounds like maybe you
should make a video about it I have my
opinion on the matter so hey let's talk
about it that's the one who's gonna play
Wonder Woman in Man of Steel 2 is gal
gadot which then peg annoy it'd be easy
to get on camera be like I don't see it
this is she's not Wonder Woman
but I'm gonna break down how and why I
feel how I feel first of all if you're
looking for a hot chick kid there are
less attractive people you could have
cast it's Wonder Woman she's pretty hot
but that doesn't make Wonder Woman it's
just one of the aspects of Wonder Woman
yeah right off the bat I will say she
does not present the physique that is
Wonder Woman she's pretty skinny so yeah
she's got a bulk up which is completely
doable so I will give her the benefit of
the doubt on that cuz that's what actors
do they bulk up for roles this is
Christian Bale before Batman Begins this
is Christian Bale in Batman Begins they
can bulk up in 1999 if he showed me a
picture of Hugh Jackman fresh off of
whatever Australian musical he was doing
at the time and you told me that's
Wolverine I'd have been like no no no a
hundred times no not in a million years
but he is Wolverines
no one's gonna argue that ever so we'll
see what she does I imagine she's
pumping iron right now to get bulked up
for Wonder Woman I have a stronger
opinion on the fact that Wonder Woman is
gonna be in Man of Steel - then who's
playing Wonder Woman cuz I don't think
she should be in Man is still - first of
all it takes away from the cool aspect
of Man of Steel - being Batman versus
Superman I feel like man is steel - is
being set up to be a Justice League
prequel not a Man of Steel sequel that's
my big problem with Iron Man - Iron Man
- did the same thing I walked out of
Iron Man - you going all right that was
an Avengers prequel did it have to
happen no I don't want to walk out of
Man of Steel - going did that have to
happen no I think it's cutting Wonder
Woman short to introduce her and someone
else is moving you feel like that's DC
Gunn and she can't handle her own movie
so we'll test it out and I imagine if
Man of Steel 2 does well and people like
gal gadot as Wonder Woman she's going to
get her own Wonder Woman moving alright
cool but while I'm watching Man of Steel
2 I'm going to be like her that's Wonder
Woman
I don't know as much about as I want to
thus I don't care I would rather have
Wonder Woman get established in her own
movie and carry her own movie that will
lead into the Justice League movie kind
of like how Marvel did with the Avengers
and the characters in the Avengers and
introducing her in Man of Steel 2 and
having it feel like she's Hawkeye hey
you know that guy you didn't really get
a lot of screen time with and you cared
least about the Avengers moving him and
now Wonder Woman and I'll be honest with
you guys if this was just last month I
would be right here telling you guys
yeah Wonder Woman in Man of Steel makes
sense because she can't carry her own
movie cuz no one cares my friends that
is not true
I have recently been engrossed in the
new 52 comics Justice League Justice
League dark Constantine read some Batman
Wonder Woman I'm telling you Wonder
Woman is a badass character she could
more than hold her own movie if they do
a Wonder Woman movie how a Wonder Woman
movie should be done it would be like
Thor meets God of War with a chick
because we think Wonder Woman we think
of that chick deflect bullets
TV and she's not really like that Roman
gods friends Zeus Ares all that cool
and Wonder Woman that could be very
cool I don't know why you have to
introduce Wonder Woman in Man of Steel
when she clearly has some awesome lore
behind her I feel like DC's jumping the
gun on this I feel I Avengers kicked ass
Iron Man 3 made his Tilian dollars
they're setting up for guardians of the
galaxy and Avengers 2 and I feel like DC
is like this is Blood River 1 in a movie
if you like to blow in their wad a
little too early on this that's not good
take time with your characters establish
that you care about your characters give
Wonder Woman her movie give Flash's own
movie feel like DC is scared now I feel
like they feel like because of the Nolan
Batman's they're done so the only thing
they have is man is steel and it was
successful so they're like anything we
do is going to springboard off of that
which in turn will compromise that
franchise they're putting all their eggs
in one basket if that basket fails if
the next movie fails because it's not
what people want they wanted a Superman
movie and they didn't get it well and
now they have nothing and look for that
god I guess that's what I got to say
about a gal gadot not too concerned
about it I imagine she'll bulk up and
she's attractive cool
the fact that Wonder Woman is debuting
on the big screen in Man of Steel 2 with
Batman feel like that might be a
throwaway unless she comes in at the
very end she's like hey guys by the way
I'm here like Wonder Woman is a
post-credit scene in Man of Steel tube
that would be fine but as a fan I'd
rather have a sequel to Superman that
has Batman in it
to clash and conflict because that's
what they do then have Superman Batman
and Wonder Woman in it and make it feel
like a Justice League prequel in the end
this movie coming out with Superman
Batman and Wonder Woman could be very
cool but call it what it is call it
Justice League beginnings or something
don't call it Man of Steel because
they'll just give people the wrong
impression so gal gadot as Wonder Woman
or more specifically Wonder Woman in Man
of Steel - what do you think about this
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more